[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys wels
heute gibt es einen wunsch rezept für
murat denn er hat mir gesagt er hätte
gern eine
pfanne und ich habe mir gedacht okay
dann kriegst du einen döner pfanne ich
mache jetzt praktisch einen döner teller
in richtig schön und zwar verpackt als
döner bohl und als bestandteil ist ihr
kennt das ja wenn ihr einen döner
bestellt hat dann könnte der insel mit
reis bestellen mit bulgur oder mit
pommes muss sagen komm ist mache ich
daheim eigentlich so gut wie nie die
gibt es immer unterwegs nur und deswegen
gibt's heute anderen bulgur dazu und ich
zeige euch mal kurz die zutaten für den
bulgur aber vorher vielleicht ganz ganz
kurz noch ich hab das fleisch ist auch
schon vorbereitet und zwar schon vor ein
paar tagen denn das fleisch solltet ihr
damit erst später dann schön dünn
schneiden könnt einfach gut vorbereiten
ich zeige euch mal kurz was ich dafür
benutzt habt ich habe hier jetzt meine
rinderrouladen die sind nicht gewürzt
nehmen dazu etwas olivenöl und meine
gewürzmischung das ist so eine gyros
gewürzmischung die ich selbst gemacht
habe haben in meiner app und auf dem
blog schreibe ich euch einfach die
einzelnen gewürze noch dazu und zwar
habe ich die gewürzmischung mal als
rezept in meinem kochbuch veröffentlicht
und deswegen benutze ich die jetzt auch
aber wie gesagt für euch schreibe ich
dann in den blogs ich nehme jetzt hier
mein olivenöl das gewürz rein früher das
ganze schön und massiere das fleisch
damit
unternehmen jetzt die rouladen schön
auseinander
damit das gewürz überall auch dran kommt
ich habe die rouladen fleisch genommen
weil es einfach schön dünn ist und ich
wirklich das gewürz überall auch habe
und kann das hier vor mir auslegen und
eine große rolle zu bereiten wie so ein
dönerspieß schön schichten und eng
aufrollen
[Musik]
und dann packt ihr euren dönerspieß in
der frischhaltefolie oder zum beispiel
in gefrierbeutel ich gebe da jetzt noch
zwei knoblauchzehen dazu und das ganze
muss jetzt wirklich schön fest
aufgewickelt werden entweder wickelt er
es auf ich habe zum glück warum ihr
gerät deswegen kann ich das schön war
comedian es gibt aber auch so kleiner
punkt warum ihr geräte ich glaube die
gibt es auch er in haushalten und
dadurch kann ich eben dem beutel den
sauerstoff entziehen und was der vorteil
ist beim warum ihr gerät das eben das
ganze schön also die marinade zieht
einfach immer schnell ein und das ist so
ein bisschen ein zeitvorteil ich kann
aber auch hier das fleisch hack um ihren
und dann hält sich einfach auch länger
im kühlschrank das heißt ich muss es
nicht heute zubereiten sondern kann es
auch morgen oder übermorgen zu bereiten
und vor allem sollte der spieß jetzt
mindestens drei stunden eingefroren
werden aber eben auch nicht komplett
durchfrieren ansonsten habt es später
bisschen schwerer mit dem schneiden
dann mache ich das
[Musik]
und ich hab das fleisch das jetzt
einfach kopiert war einfach ins
gefrierfach gestellt für etwa drei vier
stunden das reicht auch schon und dann
kann ich später schon zu schneiden aber
mich jetzt erst mal um den bulgur salat
kann und dafür nämlich zwei zwiebeln
eine knoblauchzehe etwas butter und
olivenöl 2 grüne spitz fabbrica das sind
die süßen dann habe ich hier paprika
mark und tomatenmark 300 gramm bulgur
und zwar ist das ein grober bulgur zwei
gläser wasser das sind dann 600 gramm
etwas salz und pfeffer berg bohnenkraut
oder regal oder thymian nehmen und zwei
tomaten der bulgur ist muss ich sagen
eigentlich auch schon ein eigenständiges
rezept und zwar nehmt ihr jetzt die
knoblauchzehe und die zwiebeln geschält
sie und schneidet sie einfach in feine
würfel schon mal ich muss aber auch
sagen als kind mochte ich keinen bilder
salat und auch keinen so gereist weil
ich glaube ich irgendwann einmal zu viel
hatte kennen das wenn ihr euch dann so
überfressen hat dann irgendwas dann kann
man es nicht mehr essen und so ging es
bei kultur ich konnte ihn nicht mehr
riechen aber irgendwann als erwachsene
geschaffen und jetzt mag ich es folgen
und vor allem wenn ihr hier bei dem
preis den
die butterweck last oder vegane mutter
nimmt dann ist es sogar sein pflanzlich
also weg
[Musik]
mir geht's gut
da könnt ihr hier schon mal die butter
mit dem öl erhitzen und dann die zwiebel
und knoblauch würfel schön anbraten und
da gebe ich auch gern den deckel drauf
zum einen richter nicht so sehr in der
wohnung und zum oder im haus und zum
anderen ganz einfach schneller durch bis
sie schön glasig sind und dann könnt ihr
nämlich diese spitz paprika nimmt die
grüne und die dann auch schon mal fein
würfeln
[Musik]
während ist jetzt noch anbrät kann ich
schon mal die tomaten halbieren und dann
die tomaten fein reiben und so könnt ihr
euch übrigens auch das häuten ersparen
wenn ihr nämlich hier eine reibe nimmt
und dann die tomate halbiert mit der
schnittfläche auf die reihe und dann
vorsichtig reiben dann bleibt am ende
einfach nur noch dieser haut übrig und
dann muss man das nicht mehr stehlen
vorher und eben nicht heute mit heißem
wasser man muss halt nur aufpassen aber
wenn man da wirklich ganz flach mit der
hand drauf geht dann passiert da
wirklich nix und nur noch dieser haut
übrig
[Musik]
das habe ich hier die tollen röstaromen
erzeugt und gebe jetzt tomaten und
paprika mark dazu und das paprika markt
bekommt ihr auch im türkischen
supermarkt auf dem großen gläsern und
weil ich auch selber nicht so viel
verbraucht wie meine mama zum beispiel
friere ich das ganz gerne in einzelnen
feldern ein und dann habe ich das immer
auf vorrat und hab das dann eben auch
schön portioniert und dann setzt neben
nicht schlecht so krist anbraten dann
habe ich hier schon den groben bulgur
den habe ich bereits unter fließendem
wasser einfach schön ausgewaschen sollte
man generell mit reis produkten und eben
obwohl rohr oder linsen
inhalt lebensmittel die in der natur
vorkommen und dann muss man die halt
schon waschen weil sie oft recht staubig
und schmutzig sind und könnte den
dazugeben
und mit wasser aufgießen
[Musik]
ich habe es ihr ein glas vorgenommen und
zwei gläser wasser das passt dann auch
perfekt vom verhältnis her wenn man den
gruben nimmt und jetzt einfach mit salz
und pfeffer würzen
bisschen
eckig dazu also berg von unkraut und
dann noch die tomaten die geriebenen und
dann könnt ihr den deckel nämlich drauf
geben und die hitzegrade bei kurzreisen
wirklich total reduzieren denn es gab
dann sowieso durch die top weil man ganz
gut nach also es muss man jetzt nicht
extrem kochen lassen und dann ist dieser
porsche und erledigt ich werde mich
gleich noch in den salat kümmern und
noch eine joghurt soße herstellen und
dann am ende um das fleisch zubereiten
das braucht es ungefähr sage ich noch
zehn 15 minuten bis es durch gezogen ist
und dann stelle ich es einfach
für den salat habe ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen romana salate kleinen salat
herten rotkohl karotten kleines
cherrytomaten also cocktailtomaten eine
rote zwiebel etwas zurück das ist so ein
ass kommen gewürze salz zitronensaft und
olivenöl
das war's das ist unser leckeren salat
da habe ich das rezept aber auch schon
auf meinem kanal und ich werde es
einfach den rotkohl und die karotten
einfach nur klein raspeln und entweder
könnt ihr das in der küchenmaschine
machen oder mit einer küchenmöbel
einfach machen ich werde jetzt hier
einfach ein küchengerät benutzen die
karotten die schäbig heute
nur gewaschen und hinter celle weg und
vorne das tippfehler weg
da kann ich nämlich hier den transformer
nehmen und damit das ganz einfach fein
raspeln
[Musik]
die zwiebel werde ich jetzt in feine
ringe schneiden
[Musik]
dann die salatblätter noch fein hacken
und die tomaten könnte entweder würfeln
oder einfach nur vierter wird und reicht
auf jeden fall
[Musik]
so könnte die zitrone vor dem auspressen
ein bisschen zerdrücken und massieren
nicht schneidet hier gerne noch den
anfang und das ende weg dann kommt
nämlich mehr zitronensaft aus
[Musik]
salz drauf
und so mag und öl
der senat muss jetzt nur noch verrührt
werden den stelle ich kurz zur seite und
jetzt habe ich auch noch einen joghurt
zubereitet nämlich aus einem dreieinhalb
prozentigen joghurt also diesmal keinen
zehnprozentiger dann kommt da eine
knoblauchzehe rhein und die misst ja
auch vorher nicht schälen ihr könnt sie
einfach in die knoblauchpresse geben
unter zu pressen damit salz und pfeffer
und etwas minze abschmecken und fertig
ist die döner soße und jetzt kommt
eigentlich ja eigentlich gemeinsam ende
zu salat ist fertig bulgers fertig
joghurt es fertig und ich hab ich jetzt
mein fleisch und entweder nehmt ihr euch
jetzt ein scharfes messer und schneidet
ist schön fein mit dem rad messer zum
beispiel oder ihr nehmt dann alles
schneider und ich mache das jetzt hier
einmal alles schneidern und deswegen ist
eben wichtig dass es vorher eingefroren
wird damit es einfach schön fest ist und
ich wirklich ganz dünne scheiben
schneiden kann ok los gehts dann hab ich
mal gespannt ob meinem mann der döner
schmeckt kann ich nämlich schön mm genau
ganz dünn
schneiden
perfekt
das ist wirklich wie dönerfleisch
herzlich willkommen und ich wollte schon
wie man bilder laden aufmachen pokemon
der gerät wird nie müde
der gerät schläft nie ein der gerät ist
immer vor dem chef im geschäft und
schneidet das fleisch eiweiß erreichen
ok ich kann jetzt hier aber auch schon
mal eine pfanne erhitzen tatsächlich ich
nehme dafür jetzt einen großen bräter
und dann muss das fleisch wirklich nur
ganz kurz bei hoher hitze angeboten
werden denn es ist ja extra dünn
ich finde er sollte noch mal kaputt
machen
ich bin so begeistert mein dünner wird
cool
löhner laden kommt
jetzt schön scharf anbraten und es geht
jetzt echt ganz kurz ist ja ganz dünn
[Musik]
okay es sind ist fertig heute gibt
turner mit alles unscharf wer möchte wer
meister
wird und dabei
ich würde mich ja als döner
spezialisten
bezeichnet wirklich schöner sommer in
der summe
also ich weiß auch wenn das schreiben
wo ist ein guten dünger gibt kann ich
mal ganz kurz den zuschauern 2 also
längst ja ok in stuttgart gibt es denn
artur k der super- oder
wie heißt der bkb es auch cool und auch
der y trasse so heißt es wirklich heiß
mir nicht also in stuttgart habe eine
sehr sehr hohe döner dichte und
karlsruhe karlsruhe gibt es auch zwei
richtig coole und zwar einmal die planer
der kriegsstraße genau und dann in der
kaiserpassage da ist dann wirklich der
hammer das ist
doch ich kenne und in waghäusel gibt es
jetzt seit heute auch den besten döner
das ist nämlich solisten und ich wollte
schon immer mal ein döner stand haben
sallys döner und der name döner heißt
einfach einfach drehspieß nun genau dünn
heißt dreht sich also ein dreh spies so
jetzt problemlos ja ja ich mache jetzt
gleich noch eine bowl arbeite ich mache
und was viele immer falsch verstehen ja
der döner wurde wirklich in berlin
erfunden aber nur dellwo in der
teigtasche drill ist er gewöhnt
eingemahnt gibt's der türkei schon ewig
lang aber in der teigtasche zum
mitnehmen deshalb habe ich in berlin
davon das stimmt wirklich ja
habt ihr das
doppelte portion fleisch doppelte
portion ist sehr cool oder
der türkei wird übrigens dann wird der
döner abgebogen also dass du sagst haben
wir 60 gramm 90/grüne hersteller wird
damit nicht auf seine waage getan
abgebucht hier in deutschland einfach
nur ein gemisch ansonsten müsste so sehr
schaaf schaaf mit mit charme oder alles
ist aus natürlich mit sharp damit alles
ja alle erleben heute nicht da so
jetzt ich probiere es aus aber ich bin
mit ich bin echt extrem man ja
noch mal ein lied der höhner so mini
reichs
hammerstein ist
ok in holz gemerkt soll
der durchschnitt so gut warum david salz
und geschmacksverstärker ja jetzt auch
eine billig fleisch kaffee
schmeckt anders ich finde aber beim
thema wie schmeckte besser
mit lichterketten und beim ding
schnitten auch besser beim bgv und beim
alla turca schritte auch besser warum
warum nein sage ich nichts falsches
sagen nein sagt stix warten weil die
dort fleisch die nehmen ja fettiges und
fettarmes fleisch und die mission das
ist und ich habe jetzt rinderrouladen
und ist jetzt nicht so fett wenn man die
ja auftreten anders fett ist ein
geschmacksverstärker stärker deswegen
mögen sie wollen deswegen mögen die
menschen auch mich
so auf jedem schmeckt cool aber es kommt
mit gehaltskürzungen aber es ist nicht
schlecht gut gerne aber selbst ein
chorus gewürz seien dafür das erste
stück
selber gewünscht und das was die
menschen auch nicht wissen ist der
genuss ist eigentlich ihn dönerspieß nur
schweinefleisch ja und anders bewerten
als gewürz tapezieren habe jetzt etwas
erreicht
haben ich habe euch die genauer
gewürzmischung habe ich endlich die
abgeschrieben also probiert gern mal auf
ich finde es richtig cool weil man sich
wirklich diesen döner spieß einfach
vorbereiten kann und einfrieren kann
dann kann man wirklich jederzeit mit dem
messer oder nimm alles schneider eben
schöne dünne hauchdünne scheiben
schneiden ja ab sofort ich mein alles
schneider nämlich meinen dünnen
schneider also dass bei den gewürzen
könnten würze mir wollt auch anders wenn
ihr wollt wie väter ist so etwas eine
säuerlich kai teure
fleisch
kann im 2 ich muss mal den kiwis anruf
macht's gut macht's besser macht es nach
viel spaß dabei schlecht ergeht nicht
schlecht aber schmeckt katholisch im
moment essen schmecke nicht beim thema
aber gut
machen
[Musik]
der mann könnte andere machen